- WELCOME TO OUR HUMBLE
WHOREHOUSE ABODE.
- YO, WHAT ARE YOU DOING
IN HERE?
- OH, HEY.
WEREN'T YOU SUPPOSED TO BE
ON A DATE?
- THAT'S RIGHT.
I GOT A DATE
WITH A MODEL,
AN ARCHITECTURAL MODEL.
- OH, COOL.
THESE GUYS, I TOLD THEM THEY
COULDN'T HAVE SEX IN THE HOUSE,
AND THEN IT BECAME
FORBIDDEN FRUIT, SO...
- THESE MODELS
ARE MY FORBIDDEN FRUIT.
I WANNA BE AN ARCHITECT, MAN.
- THAT'S COOL, MAN.
I'M GLAD YOU'RE PASSIONATE
ABOUT SOMETHING
BESIDES JACKHAMMER
[bleep] GIRLS.
- I DON'T TELL NOBODY
THAT [bleep].
I CAN'T TAKE THE PRANKS
AND THE TEASING.
- I'LL NEVER LET
ANYONE KNOW
YOUR TOTALLY
RESPECTABLE SECRET.
- 'CAUSE YOU KNOW WHAT'S GONNA
HAPPEN IF THEY FIND OUT.
- YEAH.
YOU'LL GET FIRED
FROM BEING A WHORE
AND INSTEAD HAVE TO PURSUE
A CAREER IN ARCHITECTURE?
- IT'S HARD TO LOOK
AT THIS BAKED POTATO
WHEN I GOT SUCH A SWEET POTATO
IN FRONT OF ME.
[both chuckle]
- YOU'RE FUNNY STILL.
THAT'S GOOD.
- THE DATE WAS OFF
TO A GREAT START.
- THANKS FOR TAKING ME OUT.
- NAH, THANK YOU
FOR TAKING ME OUT.
[both laugh]
I FEEL LIKE IMPLICITLY,
YOU UNDERSTAND ME...
- UH-HUH.
- BECAUSE, LIKE,
YOU'RE ON THE SAME LEVEL.
- WAIT, SAY THAT AGAIN.
- OTHER PEOPLE AREN'T
ON THE SAME LEVEL.
- YEAH. CAN I ASK YOU
A QUESTION?
- YOU CAN ASK ME ANYTHING
YOU WANT.
- DO YOU DATE ME TONIGHT
FOR MONEY LIKE WE DISCUSSED?
- I'M SORRY, WHAT?
- LIKE, NOT TO MESS UP
YOUR DINNER
OR, LIKE, THE VIBE
OF WHAT'S HAPPENING RIGHT NOW,
BUT YOU DEFINITELY DID
STRAIGHT-UP OFFER
TO PAY ME FOR SEX.
- NO.
- AND DINNER'S INCLUDED.
- SWEETHEART, LET ME TELL YOU
HOW IT'S GONNA GO DOWN
RIGHT NOW, OKAY?
I'M A GIGOLO NOW.
I LIVE IN
A GIGOLO HOUSE
WITH A NUMBER
OF OTHER COOL DUDES, OKAY?
IT'S DATE NIGHT,
USA TONIGHT.
I DECIDED
THAT I WOULD GRANT YOU
WITH MY PERMISSION
TO BE THE GIRL
THAT WOULD PAY ME VERY MUCH
FOR SEX TONIGHT
BECAUSE I, MY FRIEND,
AM A GIGOLO.
- THEN I'M A GIGOLO
TOO, BOBBY.
- PSSH.
YOU'RE NOT A GIGOLO.
FARLEY, YOU'RE A PROSTITUTE.
- [laughs]
AH, HA, HA.
SAY THAT [bleep] AGAIN.
- YOU'RE A PROSTITUTE.
- WHAT THE [bleep], MAN?
I CAN'T TAKE IT.
YOU DON'T GET IT, STUPID.
NO, I WAS NOT SATISFIED
WITH BOBBY'S SO-CALLED SERVICES.
STICK TO WHAT
YOU DO BEST:
HANGING OUT
WITH YOUR MOM.
- OH.
OOH.
MM.
[groans]
- WHAT...THE...[bleep]?
PETER, I SAID
NO [bleep]ING IN THE HOUSE.
- CHILL OUT, EAGLE WING.
- HAMMER, WHAT ARE
YOU DOING THERE?
AND WHAT ARE YOU PLAYING
WITH, TOYS?
- SHH.
- YOU'RE GONNA SHUSH ME?
- GOOD-BYE. I'M MOVING OUT
TO PURSUE MY PASSION.
I HOPE THAT ONE DAY
YOU ALL LOOK AROUND
AND REALIZE YOU'RE HAVING SEX
IN A HOUSE THAT I BUILT.
LOOK OUT, WORLD.
HERE COME THE HAMMER.
- FINE, YOU'LL BE BACK!
YOU'LL BE BACK, HAMMER!
- WHAT ARE YOU DOING,
EAGLE WING?
WE JUST LOST
AN AMAZING GIGOLO.
YOU KNOW WHY?
'CAUSE OF YOUR TEASIN'.
I MEAN, WHO DIED AND MADE YOU
THE KING OF GIGOLO HOUSE?
- IF YOU GOT A PROBLEM
WITH WHO'S IN CHARGE
OF THIS HOUSE,
YOU CAN TAKE IT UP WITH ME.
I AM IN THE BEDROOM
AT THE TOP OF THE STAIRS.
- OH, I KNOW
WHERE YOUR BEDROOM IS
'CAUSE IT SMELLS LIKE
CLOWN MAKEUP AND SPAGHETTI.
- NOT TONIGHT
IT DOESN'T, BRO,
BECAUSE JUST LIKE
MY FINGERS,
IT SMELLS LIKE
YOUR MOM'S [bleep].
- [inhales]
- YEAH.
- NO!
- [laughs]
GIGOLO AUDITIONS TOMORROW.
SPREAD THE WORD.
- ONE TIME WHEN I WAS
IN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL,